thank you Yasser we are here with
Rihanna report who has been an integral
part of the just included world
championship match between Ding and
Neville
um Richie you started playing with in
round one against Nepal player that
you've gotten to know so well over the
last few months tell us a bit about this
game yeah I was very surprised by his
approach no actually I of course I was
thinking to
take some small experience with me from
the match and I
felt like he's actually quite vulnerable
in French I mean 92 is not of course
there to be there you know the most
dangerous wine
um yeah of course I assume if a thing
would have gone for this um again
would have played differently but I
guess
you know knowing all
the match concluded and everything I
think he was not too ambitious to go for
something
but yeah still I mean he got a very
pleasant endgame
let's talk about it uh did he surprise
you with his Approach at all I was
really tired actually um so I didn't
prepare much and I went for
um CTX D4
uh here yeah I believe I saw this from
from yavana from my wife
it should probably uh so not from the
preparation you did during the match
which might be you know
um
speaking for the most quality
no I I think I'm not going to assume
what that means it could be good it
could be bad it's just a very solid line
for black and as it happened in the game
I ended up getting this uh
um yeah like once I did the one-sided
game but
okay some people used to lose this some
people used to draw this yeah some
people get you know in trouble with
white
what was your comfort level let's say at
this point were you feeling like you're
worse
um but it's going to be an easy defense
how are you feeling yeah of course black
is clearly worse I mean if I would want
to be really mean I would say that
following the match I wasn't worried but
um no I mean of course black is clear
livers and I was I was somewhat um
I mean I didn't get a good version in
general but I mean I think if you play
these positions extremely precisely as
black you shouldn't lose them so I was
thinking it's kind of up to me and if he
will be able to you know to to put up
maximum pressure which I mean I didn't
feel like he he did so I don't know I
kind of he kind of let me let me of the
hooker easily and I even think so kind
of turn was there ever any tension
between you know team nepo and team ding
in any way shape or form I've spotted at
the beginning of the game he wasn't
really facing you before you guys
started the game was there anything
there I mean from my side not really as
you can see from him it might be I don't
know like
yeah the match was not I mean I'm not
much to do with the match I
of course I if it was like this I think
half of the players wouldn't talk to
each other afterwards all the all the
version picture matches that has been
played already so I didn't feel like
dead but yeah he was acting a bit
peculiar before the game I don't know
maybe he was just nervous or maybe
interested in general not happy to
to be here um to play after the match
yeah
you mentioned that you were quite tired
did you do anything in particular to try
to
re-energize yourself after such a
difficult month in Asana yeah obviously
I'll try and try but you know as you can
see from my play I didn't feel like I
succeeded so yeah
um I just like take take it easy yeah
have fun and
you know it was sweet at the end but it
wasn't really fun so I know the work of
a second you don't sleep during the
night things
for for more fun actually I have friends
here so I feel yeah more or less nice my
place is probably very poor but um okay
that's another story it's just beginning
Richie thank you very much for joining
us we'll see you in the next rounds guys
back to you